Get these people back
to their classes.
I thank you so very much.
So this is what the
multiverse looks like!
I do know how hard I make it
to appreciate me, often.
Danger is my business.
You know, I had no idea
what I was doing.
Stood out here in
front of you all,
really just a kid.
I went out, you know,
and I never thought that
I would be back here.
You know,
I'm just trying to matter
and live a good life
and make work
that means
something to somebody.
And you have all made me feel
that I might have accomplished
that tonight.
I told the history teacher
of my plan.
and he said, “Fox, you're
never going to be cute forever.”
I had no idea how to
respond to that.
I found desire for what
I do early in my life
and I’m lucky because I had people
who encouraged that desire.
The people who taught me, good or
bad, how to fail, how to love.
I would not be standing here
if it weren't for
Mr. Rawley Farnsworth, who was
my high school drama teacher.
I have to thank everyone
from the very onset
of my career,
Mr. Caton-Jones.
Kevin Misher and
Stacey Snider and Stacey Sher.
And I can't believe I'm
remembering everybody's name.
For believing
that I could do it.
And now tonight I have this.
I'm going to find you
all individually,
and I'm going to thank you
along with my friends
who I love so much.
I'm going to hug
the hell out of you
when the feeling reenters my body.
Whatever it is we look up to,
whoever it is we're chasing.
To that, I say, alright,
alright, alright.
You just got to keep livin’ man.